mes chers amis
mes chers amis mes chers amis je suis
français vous êtes français
nous sommes français
c'est une chance d'être français c'est
un privilège d'être français mais ce que
nous en souvenons assez est-ce que même
nous comprenons ce que veut dire être
français
cette identité si précieuse que nous
avons évité et que nous devrions à
chaque instant mérité avons-nous
pleinement conscience de ce qu'elle
représente
elle nous accompagne cette identité
comme l'air que l'on respire
nous pensons que c'est ainsi que se fuit
toujours ainsi et que ça ne changera pas
est ce si sûr
depuis plusieurs années le doute a
commencé à naître en nous la france que
nous avons cru éternelle comme ces
landes de granit breton comme ces grands
plateaux de l'aubrac
la france tente français se demandent
n'est-elle pas en train de se dissoudre
de s'effacer de disparaître à coups de
renoncement à kout l'acheter à coups de
recul a que deux démissions cette
question de la france et de sa pérennité
est essentielle car elle constitue le
véritable sens des échéances politiques
qui nous attendent dans moins d'un an
dans les années qui viennent mes chers
amis mes chers compatriotes la france
restera-t-elle la france c'est le
premier défi c'est le plus grand c'est
le plus fondamental et cette
interrogation
la france restera telle la france c'est
cette interrogation qui explique la
douleur confusément ressentez par des
millions de femmes et d'hommes qui
depuis trop
d'années souffre de ne pas être entendu
de ne pas être compris de ne pas être
présenté et d'entendre à longueur
d'émissions de télévisions des radios
des idées qui ne sont pas les leurs
pourquoi pourquoi la question de la
france et de son identité se pose-t-elle
maintenant parce que la france mes chers
compatriotes est de nouveau menacée par
cette maladie qui la rattrape de loin en
loin que le général de gaulle cher
gérante avait appelé le renoncement à
certaines périodes de son histoire la
france se trouve face aux périls
d'oublier qui est laid d'abdiquer ses
rêves d'unité et de grandeur de voir sa
volonté aboli qu'en parlant de
renoncement jeudi la france en vérité
l'expression est sans doute inapproprié
elle peut même être injuste car cette
maladie du renoncement n'est pas la
maladie du peuple le peuple en la
circonstance le peuple de france et le
gardien douloureux de la france dont il
pressent et redoute le déclin et dont il
grains le naufrage ce n'est pas le
peuple qui renonce car le peuple a
compris de quoi il retournait
le peuple est la victime de ce désastre
et quand on refuse de lui parler c'est
le peuple que l'on abandonne l'esprit du
renoncement
c'est la maladie d'une partie de nos
élites qui nous disent comment penser
celles qui prétendent savoir ce qui est
correct
celles qui voudraient nous imposer ce
qu'on aurait le droit de dire est ce
qu'il faudrait taire la maladie du
renoncement c'est quand les élites ne
sent plus le désir ni la force
d'entendre l'histoire de la france
son identité culturelle
son identité morale et j'ose le mot son
ordi dans son identité spirituelle car
la france pour moi c'est un corps la
france est un esprit
la france est une âme et bien l'esprit
de renoncement c'est donc un long
mouvement commencé il ya près d'un
demi-siècle quand des jeunes gens
écrivaient sur les murs de paris
il est interdit d'interdire jouissons
sans entraves ici a commencé à germer le
désastre la société française a pensé
qu'elle avait gagné la bataille quand
les barricades eurent été démontées et
que la vie avait repris son cours mais
en fait le poison de cette idéologie il
est interdit d'interdire se répandait
d'abord souterrain est de plus en plus
visible il eu je suis le premier à le
reconnaître
de grandes et belles choses dans
l'émancipation conquise par les jeunes
et par les femmes en 68
mais s'il ya une part de lumière dans
l'esprit de 68
il ya aussi une part d'ombré dont on
mesure seulement aujourd'hui
l'importance
cette part d'ombré a perdu dans la rue a
perdu dans les urnes mais je veux dire
parce que c'est ma vérité qu'elle a
gagné progressivement dans les têtes
elle a trouvé un puissant relais cette
part d'ombré au tournant des années 80
dans le combat des communautés du
communautarisme et dans la société qu'on
a voulu nous imposer en la présentant
comme un progrès en nous disant vous
n'avez pas d'identité votre identité
c'est le communautarisme et la société
multiculturelle là s'est dénoué le
désastre
la nouvelle idéologie dominante
sherman fini et je veux vous parler vrai
imprégné bien au-delà des rangs
politiques de la gauche
nombreux furent touchés y compris à
droite
elle a frappé subrepticement en chantant
la douce mélodie des accommodements
raisonnables des reculs prétendument
acceptable de l'universalisme et du
multiculturalisme revendiqué elle a
murmuré à l'oreille
ne vous inquiétez pas peuple de france
ne soyez pas si pessimiste accepté le
nouvel ordre des choses
au fond je veux le dire du fond de mon
coeur l'esprit de démission était devenu
moderne voilà l'idéologie dominante dont
nous voulons plus il voyait dans la
nation un obstacle au progrès le mot
même la nation a fini un comble par
devenir sulfureux et la repentance la
repentance dont ils nous ont rebattu les
oreilles et est devenu le maître mot
être intelligent
c'était se repentir dans l'amour charnel
de la patrie dans la révérence pour son
passé plus que millénaire dans le culte
de nos morts dans l'admiration pour les
paysages dans la vénération notre
héritage de nos moeurs et bien cette
nouvelle pensée dénoncé une attitude
comment dire
réactionnaire un conservatisme de
mauvais aloi
une ignorance du mouvement et de
l'avenir
pour eux la nation n'est pas un corps
social unis par une histoire une
identité un rêve commun la nation était
devenu un périmètre
riddick dans lequel se développerait la
liberté des individus et des groupements
d'intérêt les communautés et les
minorités on ne parle plus de nation on
parle de communauté de liberté de
l'individu de groupements aux yeux des
idéologues de la gauche mondaine et de
la pensée unique c'est la même chose
les droits de chacun mais chers amis
doivent désormais prévaloir sur les
règles qui s'imposent à tous le bon
gouvernement est alors devenu non pas
celui qui conduit avec énergie un projet
collectif
mais celui qui donne toujours davantage
aux groupes et aux individus
il n'y a plus de france il ya des
groupes et il ya des individus toujours
moins d'intérêt supérieur de la nation
toujours moins d'autorité de l'état
toujours moins de règles communes car
elles seraient autant de brides sur les
individus on voit le résultat de cette
idéologie aujourd'hui dans le climat de
désordre d'anarchie et de perdre général
d'autorité regardez mes chers
compatriotes
comment voudrait que nous traitions la
jeunesse rien au fond ne parle davantage
que cela ait eu l'autorisation de vous
dire ce que je pense parfait obliger les
enfants à prendre quelle attaque cruelle
à leur libre arbitre m des notes
quel épouvantable discrimination
interdire la consommation du cannabis
quel esprit répressif empêcher que l'on
rap et que longtemps saverdun sur la
mémoire de centaines de milliers de
soldats morts pour la france
quel retour nauséabond de l'ordre moral
pour libé le piratage sur internet
quelle vision liberticide considérer que
les enfants doivent respect aux
professeurs
quelle conception archaïque de la
relation pédagogique expliqué que les
femmes et les hommes quoique ego sont
différents quel docile soumission à la
construction sociale des genres le
sharan est un désastre
je ne serai jamais et mes amis s'ils le
savent jamais le chantre du
conservatisme tout mon identité s'oppose
à l'immobilisme
je n'ai jamais défendu un ordre
réactionnaires qui m'est totalement
étranger mais j'affirme aujourd'hui ici
chez vous chère martine que l' équilibre
entre les droits et les devoirs
l'équilibré entre les droits de
l'individu et les impératifs de la
société est en passe d'être rompu et que
sans ces équilibres la nation s'effondre
c'est le spectacle auquel nous assistons
aujourd'hui
c'est toujours cher daniel plus de
droits pour chacun c'est le progrès
alors toujours moins de règles qui
s'imposent à tous c'est l'idéal
et à l'arrivée c'est la confusion c'est
la pagaille
c'est le chaos c'est la loi du plus fort
si seul l'individu souverain est sacrée
alors ce qui est commun ce qui unit ce
qui rassemble et désacralisé on atteint
la chose commune se dire est ce public 1
en français on dit la république et nous
voici donc au coeur de la problématique
ce qui est désacralisé quand on
s'attaque à la nation c'est la
république et ce qui est attaquée quand
on désacralise la république c'est la
nation parce qu'il n'ya qu'une seule
souveraineté c'est la souveraineté du
peuple
une partie de nos élites n'aime pas la
communauté nationale
ils la jugent archaïque et régressive
mais elle adore les communautés
particulières au nom de la sacro-sainte
reconnaissance du droit à la différence
au fond pour cette partie d'élite la
nation se résumer à cela la
juxtaposition plus ou moins harmonieuse
de communautés reconnues dans leurs
droits particuliers de communauté
nationale n'y en a plus en pensant ainsi
ils trahissent la plus belle conquête de
la république qui s'appelle le bien
commun l'unité du peuple
par delà ces différences la communion
oui la communion dans un projet unique
quel que soit son origine sociale quelle
que soit son origine ethnique
quelle que soit sa religion ou quelles
que soient ses opinions car l'idée que
nous nous faisons nous les républicains
du bien commun est indifférente absolue
mentales différentes à la race ou à
l'origine être citoyen français ne doit
rien notre naissance et tout à notre
volonté
la volonté de vivre ensemble
la volonté de s'inscrire dans une
histoire commune la volonté de suivre
les mêmes usages les mêmes coutumes si
cela la république le refus absolu de se
laisser enfermer dans son milieu social
dans son origine ethnique
dans sa confession religieuse je n'ai
d'ailleurs pas plus de nier ces
différences parce que rachida le sait
bien c'est dans l'espace civique que
l'on peut se constituer comme un égal de
chacun comme citoyens que l'on peut se
réunir
fraternellement avec tous
et quand on peut se dépasser vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'on a un avenir commun
c'est cela la république
c'est cela la nation et c'est cela que
je n'accepte pas que l'on veut détruire
son tour et agissions un avenir commun
pour chacun de nos enfants
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau
quelle que soit sa religion quelle que
soit l'histoire de sa famille quelle que
soit l'histoire de ses parents
je sais ce n'est pas un discours
politique j'entends déjà les critiques
ouhlala oui moi ça me fait plaisir de
parler comme ça et je vais vous dire que
c'est toute une vie politique pour moi
de vous dire ce que je vous dis ce soir
parce qu'il m'a fallu beaucoup de
maturation ou de maturité pour y arriver
la vérité c'est que la gauche culturelle
celle qui prétend dominé les esprits qui
voudraient imposer ses vues à tous
n'aime plus le peuple vous savez
pourquoi il n'aime plus le peuple parce
que le peuple aux yeux de la gauche
culturelle et réactionnaire le peuple
est frileux
le peuple est sécuritaire et le peuple
n'a pas compris où serait le progrès la
gauche culturelle a donc trouvé un
opprimé de substitution au nom duquel
elle peut faire croisade la gauche
culturelle ne fait plus croisade au nom
du peuple
encore moins au nom des travailleurs ils
ont oublié le travail lagos culturel
fait la croisade au nom des minorités
puisque le peuple est devenu
réactionnaire on change son fusil
d'épaulé et on vénère une nouvelle idole
au professe une nouvelle religion
on se prosterne donc désormais devant
les communautés les communautés d'abord
les communautés toujours et 2012 c'est
une honte
au regard de l'esprit de la république
tant le président hollande a menti aux
communautés auxquelles s'adressait les
unes après les autres
c'est la vérité
quelle est la conséquence de ce
communautariste reconnu dans toute sa
majesté c'est la tyrannie des minorités
et la tyrannie des minorités mes chers
amis fait reculer chaque jour davantage
la république
si une poignée de lycéens bloquent
alizés faut se résigner subir c'est une
poignée d addis bloque la construction
d'un aéroport nécessaires au
développement économique de toute une
région
faut se résigner et subir si une poignée
de gens du voyage bloquent
scandaleusement une autoroute faut se
résigner et subir c'est une poignée
bernard de casseurs bloc une loi de
réforme du marché du travail devenu
d'ailleurs vide de toute aspérité faut
se résigner il subir c'est une poignée
d'islamistes radicaux prennent en otage
un quartier il faudrait se résigner et
subir et bien moi je vous le dis je
n'accepte aucune de ces résolutions
c'est d'ailleurs bien pire
c'est d'ailleurs bien pire car la
minorité n'a plus les mêmes droits que
les autres car elle en a déjà
j'y viendrai karnas désormais bien
davantage une minorité a le droit de
bloquer des raffineries
la majorité n'a pas le pouvoir de se
déplacer une minorité a le droit de
prendre en otage la préparation de
l'euro la majorité d'un droit que de
subir une minorité pas enfreindre la loi
la majorité se fait elle un devoir la
respecter une minorité peut imposer la
fermeture d'une centrale nucléaire
la majorité n'aura d'autre choix que de
payer une minorité veut imposer un
fondamentalisme religieux et traiter les
femmes comme des êtres inférieurs
la majorité des musulmans français qui
ne demande qu'à s'intégrer devraient en
payer les conséquences
je n'accepte pas de subir
et vient le politiquement correct c'est
la tyrannie des minorités au
politiquement correct
c'est par exemple de dire il n'y a aucun
problème d'immigration et si vous pensez
qu'il ya un problème d'immigration c'est
d'ajouter vous êtes et no fun
si vous dites il y a des molenbeek dans
les banlieues françaises
le politiquement correct c'est de dire
mais vous jeter de l'huile sur le feu
une minorité pense qu'il n'y a pas de
problème d'immigration pas de problème
de communautariste par problèmes de
sécurité la majorité pensent le
contraire
mais c'est la minorité qui aujourd'hui
décide de ce qu'il convient de dire et
pire de ce qu'il convient de penser le
politiquement correct c'est la police de
la pensée exercer parce qu'ils sont
minoritaires dans le pays mais
majoritaire dans une partie des élites
nous n'en voulons plus voilà que j'avais
envie de vous dire
ces idéologues ont trahi la grande
promesse du xviiie siècle celle de la
révolution française
parce que j'appelle un extrémiste des
droits individuels des droits
communautaires du triomphe des minorités
mais ils ont aussi trahi et la grande
promesse du xxème siècle celle de la
construction européenne on transforme en
cette magnifique espérance en un espace
vide vide de légitimité démocratique
un espace personnel un espace anonyme
un espace technocratique est ce vraiment
à l'europe de réglementer la puissance
des aspirateurs la taille des mangeoires
et des perchoirs à poules dans les
élevages et qui tout à fait raisonnable
que l'europe produisent tout cela dans
une architecture institutionnelle
tellement compliqué qu'en dehors des
lobbys et des experts personne n'y
comprend rien si ce n'est que le peuple
en est l'absent dans le même temps
l'europe produit ces milliers de normes
sourcilleuse schengen et parterres
transformant notre continent en passoire
dans le même temps l'europe produit ces
milliers de normes nous affaiblissons la
croissance européenne pour détaler assez
loin dans la coopération économique et
financière
dans le même temps leurs produits ces
milliers de normes nous sommes cinq
capable d'en finir avec ces barbares de
l'état islamique en syrie l'europe est
tatillonne
là où elle est superfétatoire et là où
elle serait nécessaire elle est
inefficace
les prétendus progressis nous avait
proposé troquer nos états nations ces
vieilleries révolue d'un passé qu'il
fallait dépasser mais il n'avait pas dit
que dans cet ensemble nouveau on
passerait le peuple à la trappe au
profit d'une gouvernance anonyme que
l'on comprenne bien c'est parce que je
suis l'avocat déterminée de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen que je ne supporte pas le
dévoiement de cet idéal de liberté dans
le triomphe des égoïsmes et la tyrannie
des minorités c'est parce que hanté par
le spectre des tranchées des charniers
des camps de la mort qui ont défiguré
l'europe
je suis mis dans passionnés de
l'espérance européenne que je ne
supporte pas le dévoiement de cet idéal
dans la constitution progressive d'un
espace juridique vide de toute
légitimité démocratique
eh bien je vais vous faire partager ce
besoin
ce besoin d'agir contre l'abaissement de
notre pays
l'urgence de contribuer à ce que notre
nation se relève renaissent comme
communauté nationale
consciente d'elle-même désireuse de se
survivre c'est le ressort de mon
engagement c'est la raison de mon retour
parmi vous dans ce combat pour la
renaissance de la france il ya peu quand
on parlait
il ya peu quand on parlait de contrôle
de l'immigration
quand on parlait d'identité quand on
parlait déchéance de nationalité
on se faisait traiter de fasciste mais
les esprits évoluent mais la foule se
lève mais le peuple se redresse et dit
ça suffit
et je voudrais développer devant vous
une idée sensible nickel je crois
profondément
ce qui paradoxalement a permis ce réveil
de la conscience nationale
c'est précisément la question de
l'immigration est celle de l'islam
pendant des décennies l'intégration
c'était le devoir pour le nouvel
arrivant sur notre territoire de se
fondre dans la communauté nationale
d'adopter notre langue notre culture nos
moeurs le minoritaire s'intégrer dans la
majorité et devenait à son tour le
légataire de la mémoire et de l'histoire
collective
nous n'étions pas tous les héritiers
directs de clovis mais tous nous nous
reconnaissions dans cette enceinte comme
un parce que tous nous étions français
et puis l'ordre des facteurs étaient
inversés nous avons dit aux candidats à
l'entrée sur notre territoire nous
allons vous prendre comme vous êtes
c'est nous qui allons nous adapter à
vous intégrer désormais cela voulait
dire la majorité va s'adapter à ces
minorités accepter leur langue leurs
valeurs leurs moeurs et s'excuser d'être
elle-même et voilà comment nous avons vu
des drapeaux étrangers à la place du
drapeau tricolore dans nos stades de
football où l'on sifflé la marseillaise
des médecins qu'ils ont refusé le droit
de s'occuper des femmes dans nos
quartiers et des revendications
scandaleuse d'horaires différencié pour
les hommes et pour les femmes dans les
piscines
cette réalité nous n'en voulons pas
alors cela ne gêne pas cela ne gêne pas
nos prétendus progressiste puisqu'une
considère écoutez bien que le
dépassement de notre identité est la
condition du nouvel universalisme un
universalisme tellement formidable qui
défait les liens et abolit les
frontières oil résultat ça fait envie
cela ne gêne pas nos prétendus
progressiste mais ça la gêne le peuple
l'immigration massive et le
communautarisme on crée une prise de
conscience du fait qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui ne tournait plus rond
la prise de conscience est aussi née de
la confrontation avec un islam
identitaire je ne parle pas de l'islam
général chez rachida que l'on confesse
dans l'intimité de sa vie privée
je parle de l'islam militant qui se
présente à nous comme un bloc et qui
voudraient imposer à ses fidèles des
règles de vie contraignante dirigeants
fermement leur comportement et leur
dictant leur moeurs
je parle non pas de l'islam de la vie
privée de chacun je parle d'un islam
prosélyte et intégristes qui vous dit
comment manger comment vous habiller
quel rapport entretient avec le sexe
opposé quel rituel doivent fonder votre
journée bref qui classe votre vie
quotidienne entre ce qui est permis et
ce qui ne l'est pas le problème c'est
que ces moeurs si contraignantes ne sont
pas celles de notre tradition
je veux être clair dans cette affaire
chacun a le droit de vivre sa religion
les musulmans comme les autres mais cher
françois baroin dans la conformité
stricte aux principes de la laïcité et
dans l'harmonie avec le mode de vie
français
jamais jamais je n'accepterai
jamais je n'accepterai que les français
de confession musulmane soit stigmatisée
amalgames et à quelques barbares janice
parce que jamais je n'oublierai le
sacrifice et le sang versé des musulmans
français lors des deux guerres mondiales
parce que quand on va fédérer no more on
ne demande pas à choisir entre les
confessions religieuses
jamais je n'oublierai la dette que nous
avons contracté à jamais à l'endroit des
harkis qui aimait tellement la france et
que nous avons honteusement abandonné le
cher gérard nous devons urgemment fixer
les règles d'un nouvel islam de france
sinon je le dis avec gravité notre
société va courir de grands risques
d'affrontement est ce qu'ils
contesteront mes propos sont ceux qui
veulent nier la réalité
nous nous voulons la regarder en face et
la confrontation mes chers amis a été
saisissant si on permettait
bouleversante parce que d'un côté il y
avait notre société qui ne se
reconnaissaient plus d'autres règles que
les droits de chaque individu à vivre
selon son bon plaisir et de l'autre une
contre-société d'un islam
fondamentaliste qui voulaient assujettir
si fidèle à une loi dont l' empire est
intraitable
d'un côté notre société qui est prête à
sacrifier sa cohésion sur l'autel de la
liberté des individus qui la composent
de l'autre une contre société qui au
contraire voudrait sacrifié la liberté
de chacun de ses membres sur l'autel de
l'unité des moeurs qu'elle leur impose
cette double confrontation à une
émigration massive et communautariser et
un islam intégriste minoritaire a
souligné par contraste la dissolution
absolue de nos liens l'affaiblissement
de nos institutions
et la remise en cause de nos modes de
vie sellier mais combien de fois ai-je
entendu le cri de souffrance de femmes
et d'hommes de bonne volonté qui sentait
confusément que la france dans pays dans
lequel ils sont nés et qui donne un sens
à leur vie qu'ils ont reçu de leurs
parents et qui voudrait transmettre à
leurs enfants étaient en train de
disparaître
l'immense ethnologue lévi strauss a dit
mieux que tout autre que le souci d'un
peuple attaché à sa culture à son style
de vie de veiller sur son particularisme
n'est en rien pathologique
il est au contraire plein de vitalité
pourquoi dans la société multiculturelle
qu'ils veulent nous imposer tout le
monde aurait le droit de cultiver sa
différence
tout le monde sauf la majorité tout le
monde sauf le peuple français qui
commettrait un crime contre l'altérité
en voulant demeurer lui même chacun a le
droit de se battre pour son identité
mais nous les français nous n'aurions
pas le droit de nous battre au nom de la
nation française c'est un scandale
alors nous n'avons nous n'avons pas plus
de droits que les autres mais je veux
affirmer ici chaque christian que nous
n'avons pas moins on pourra lutter
contre tout cela en prenant telle ou
telle mesure particulière interdire le
voile enseignements de la laïcité en
étant plus ferme mais ça ne servira à
rien si nous les français nous ne nous
ont pas avec notre histoire nous ne
renions pas avec notre identité nous ne
renions pas avec notre projet en tant
que nation il s'agit en aucune manière
de revenir un nationalisme d'exclusion
intérieur et d'agressions extérieures
dont nous avons vu les horreurs défiguré
le 20e siècle et pas davantage d'épousés
nationaliste de repli de recul jamais je
n'accepterai la moindre complaisance
avec les dirigeants du front national et
avec leur vidéo logis jamais
et de ce point de vue je veux dire à mes
amis du nord combien nous nous sommes
réjouis de la formidable victoire de
xavier bertrand et toutes les équipes
parce que quand même j'aime mieux les
hauts de france avec xavier qu'avec
quelqu'un d'autre
ya une ligne rouge ya une ligne rouge
que je n'accepterai jamais qu'elle soit
franchie mais le réveil de la nation
qu'elle je vous appelle c'est le réveil
des nations avec ses valeurs de liberté
de tolérance de fraternité de solidarité
laïcité la république c'est le réveil de
la nation qui tiendrait compte de
l'immense espérance européenne
c'est pour cela que je combats la
société multiculturelle que nous propose
la gauche mais je combats aussi la
société isolée repliée sclérose et
flétrie que nous propose extrême droite
je ne crois me ans la dissolution naïve
de la nation néant son rétrécissement
mesquin et craintif nous les français
nous n'avons pas avoir peur du monde
si la france est puissante
économiquement si elle est unie autour
de ses valeurs
si elle est sûre d'elle-même mais la
france doit affronter le vent du large
sans crainte
elle peut dialoguer avec le reste du
monde elle doit s'ouvrir à l'innovation
et au progrès elle doit être audacieuse
c'est notre destin véritable et c'est
cela qui est conforme à notre histoire
et notre tempérament
alors il y a des moments de notre
histoire ou en plus profond de
l'adversité se lève une voix intérieure
qui nous dit debout debout peuple de
france ces moments on les a tous appris
à l'école
ces jeunes d'arc quand elles marchent
sur orléans c'est dumouriez qui arrête
les prussiens avec des soldats qui sont
restés dans l'histoire de france a
jamais parce qu'ils étaient pieds nus
mais c'est bonaparte qui au pont
d'arcole saisi la hampe du drapeau et
marche à la tête de ses troupes
c'est le tegra qui reprend le flambeau
et galvanise les français en disant des
rafales d'acclamations vont accueillir
nos étendard vainqueur tordu de sang et
de larmes
c'est l'histoire de france c'est de
gaulle oui c'est de gaulle seuls à
londres entouré de quelques aristocrates
de quelques marins pêcheurs de quelques
têtes brûlées qui dit je suis la france
la france combattante
la france qui ne se rendra jamais et
bien le ratio n'est de nous remettre
debout
pour être de nouveau les fils d'une
vieille histoire qui sera continuée
c'est au peuple
mes chers amis que nous devons consacrer
toute notre attention
le peuple veut que nous rétablissions la
sécurité en mettant hors d'état de nuire
les délinquants le peuple veut que nous
rétablissions l'ordre public en arrêtant
les casseurs
le peuple veut l'identité contre le
communautarisme le peuple autorités
contre la chienlit
le peuple ne veut plus de la cgt qui
voudraient imposer sa loi contre la
majorité
eh bien c'est ce que nous allons faire
c'est ce que nous allons faire parce que
c'est le peuple qui le veut nous allons
restaurer la représentativité tout dire
avant tout faire après nous allons
recevoir un mandat clair du peuple et ne
recevoir le mandat que du peuple c'est
le recours au référendum chaque fois que
nécessaire pour retremper la légitimité
du gouvernement dans le suffrage
universel
c'est réformer notre démocratie sociale
pour interdire que des organisations si
évidemment minoritaires bloque les
réformes nécessaires
je le dis ici vous avez été frappé par
temps d'inondation et où c'est un
scandale que des organisations
corporatistes et minoritaires impose des
souffrances à une population qui a déjà
tellement souffert des intempéries
c'est un scandale
nommer les choses sans détour nos mails
réel c'est dire que la france est un
pays d'empreintes et de tradition
chrétienne
un pays le nôtre qui est né du baptême
de clovis
il ya plus de 1500 ans un pays d'église
un pays de cathédrale un pays dhabi un
pays calvaire un pays dont tant de
grands philosophes furent des penseurs
chrétiens les chrétiens ne gouverne pas
la france c'est cela la séparation de
l'église et de l'état françois c'est la
définition même de la laïcité
chacun lit est libre de pratiquer le
culte de son choix et les religions ne
rien avoir dans le pouvoir temporel mais
ici c'est un pays chrétien dans sa
culture dans ses moeurs c'est un pays
ouvert
simply accueillant ce un pays tolérant
la france et c'est ce pays la france que
doivent respecter ceux qui veulent vivre
en france nos compatriotes
de confession juive qui sont présents
nos compatriotes de confession juive qui
sont présents sur l'autre notre sol
depuis près de deux mille ans et qui ont
tout enrichi nos sciences mozart nos
industries qui ont si souvent donné leur
sang pour le drapeau dont les ancêtres
reçu la croix de sainte hélène où
reposent dans le sanctuaire de douaumont
ou furent ensevelis sur les chemins du
vercors ils le savent bien et ça ne les
a jamais empêchés d'être pleinement
juifs et d'être pleinement français
cette politique de la nation devra donc
défendre les droits essentiels d'un
régime politique et dans les droits
essentiels l'égalité entre les hommes et
femmes il n'est pas acceptable dans
notre pays que l'on veuille interdire
aux jeunes filles de porter des
pantalons ou des jupes courtes
il n'est pas acceptable qu'on les
injures et au motif qu'elles sont
amoureuses de l'homme de leur choix il
n'est pas acceptable qu'un ministre de
la république créée sur un plateau de
télévision ou un homme refuse de lui
serrer la main
parce que c'est une femme si vous vivez
en france
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
vous devez la respecter
car telle est notre identité une
identité non négociable tout comme est
non négociable la liberté d'opinion
d'expression et droits essentiels y
compris pour critiquer la religion dès
lors qu'on respecte ceux qui y croient
je suis chrétien les plaisanteries de
mauvais goût contre l'église ne me font
pas rire mais je suis français et je me
battrai pour qu'on ait le droit de faire
ses caricatures ce qui est vrai du
catholicisme est vrai de l'islam et je
n'accepte pas cette police de la pensée
qui sous prétexte d' islamophobie
voudrait restaurer le délit de blasphème
en france on a le droit de critiquer les
religions toutes les religions quelles
que soient ses religions qui ne le
comprend pas
ne mérite pas d'être français le raciste
contre les personnes insupportable le
droit à critiquer les croyances les
doctrines les idéologies quelles
qu'elles soient à prescriptibles si vous
vivez en france vous respecter cela car
telle est notre identité
cette politique de la nation braquo
reconstruire l'école je parle de l'école
comme creuset de la nation fabrique de
citoyens depuis des décennies les
militants de ce désastre partie
pédagogique au nom de l'adaptation à la
diversité des origines et des parcours
au nom de la lutte contre la
discrimination se sont échinés à
détruire méthodiquement le respect de
l'autorité
l'apprentissage de la langue la
transmission notre histoire nationale de
nos moeurs de nos valeurs de la manière
de vivre
ils ont détruit ce qu'on appelait les
humanités et bien nous les
reconstruirons car l'école mes chers
amis doit être le conservatoire de la
culture française le conservatoire des
valeurs de la république et même le
conservatoire du savoir-vivre français
cette politique de la nation devra
consacrer la restauration de l'autorité
je m'inscris dans une tradition
politique je n'ai connu qu'un qui de
bonaparte au général de gaulle considère
que l'autorité la condition de la
liberté sans l'autorité c'est la loi de
la jungle et la loi de la jungle et les
durs pour le faible sans l'autorité
le casseur ou le braqueur fracasse la
vie du paisible commerçants le petit
voyou terrorise le shass adolescents
les bandes de bons à rien empêche le
citoyen ordinaire de dormir et l'intérêt
l'intimident pour l'empêcher de se
plaindre sont l'autorité une poignée de
gauchistes debout la nuit et cocher le
jour
séquestre un petit patron et bloque une
usine sans l'autorité une poignée de
salafistes répandent une idéologie
délétère dont vous l'opa sur le sol de
la république française
et bien mes chers amis l'autorité je la
revendique je l'assumé je respecte la
liberté je respecte la contradiction je
respecte le débat mais force doit rester
au peuple souverain
le peuple français est à la loi à la loi
de la république
voilà la tradition politique qui est la
mienne
et pour finir j'ai été chef de l'état
j'ai exercé le pouvoir pendant cinq ans
dans des conditions terribles françois
éric masculine vous en souvenez celle de
la plus grasse kehl économique et
financière traversée par le monde depuis
aujourd'hui quel gâchis avec des taux
d'intérêt qui n'ont jamais été aussi bas
un prix du pétrole extrêmement
compétitif avec un taux de change euro
contre dollar particulièrement favorable
à voir une croissance si faible un taux
de chômage si élevé malgré les
radiations et stages bidons deux fois le
niveau de l'allemagne ou du royaume uni
quel épouvantable gâchis heureusement
que les socialistes n'étaient pas aux
manettes en 2009
que serait devenue la france est bien
être président de la république
française
c'est se tenir au niveau de l'histoire
surtout quand à mon mauvais de
dissolution souffle sur la verena
vénérable nations dont nous sommes les
héritiers pour présider ce pays pour la
lucidité faut du courage faut de
l'autorité
il faut surtout se tenir au dessus des
petits compromis des petits calculs des
petits arrangements pour n'avoir qu'une
fidélité la fidélité au peuple souverain
et n'avoir qu'une obsession la grandeur
de la nation faut mettre look le peuple
au coeur de tout le peuple français je
veux non seulement que nous lui rendions
la parole et donc la dignité
mais je veux aussi que nous lui rendions
l'hommage qu'il mérite
oui hommage au peuple français qui a
façonné les paysages de la france de ses
mains et qui a ensemencé la terre
française de sa peine oui hommage au
peuple de france qui génération après
génération a conquis sa liberté sur les
servitudes sur les corvées et surtout
les privilèges et dieu sait que notre
pays en a compté oui hommage au peuple
français qui a vu mourir tant de fois le
plus beau de sa jeunesse pour que la
jeunesse avenir
celle qui n'était encore qu'une
possibilité puisse naître libre et
française oui hommage au peuple français
qui c'est qui va devoir transformer la
france pour la laisser encore plus forte
oui hommage au peuple français qui veut
que l'on s'adresse à lui comme un grand
peuple et non pas comme un conglomérat
de clientèle électorale hommage au
peuple français qui veut entendre la
vérité est que la soupe et du mensonge
depuis plus de quatre ans hommage au
peuple français auxquels nous devons
rendre les sacrifices que lui n'a jamais
refusé à la france est bien le peuple
l'autorité de l'état nous le rétablirons
le peuple veut que soit reconnu le
travail et le mérite
nous les réhabiliterons le peuple qu'en
soit un prix tablent sur le respect de
nos valeurs nous le saurons le peuple
veut qu'il n'y ait pas de droits sans
devoirs et bien nous reprendrons notre
système social autour des droits et des
devoirs et celui qui n'assurera pas
assez de voir nord
droit le peuple n'en peut plus de la
multiplication des taxes et des impôts
eh bien nous mettrons fin au matraquage
fiscal
le peuple n'en peut plus de puissance le
peuple de la fin des zones de non droit
eh bien nous rétablirons la république
sur tout le territoire
mes chers amis vous l'avez compris nous
avons tous un devoir
battons-nous pour la france battons-nous
pour la france parce que la france nous
dépasse et la france deux sublimes
battons nous pour notre langue pour
notre culture que nous n'avons pas le
droit de laisser disparaître
battons nous pour nos parents qui nous
ont transmis en héritage bomo cette
patrie la patrie française battons nous
pour que nos enfants retrouvent
confiance dans l'avenir et ne soient pas
des désabusés ou des désespérés au
démarrage de leur vie battons nous pour
que la france soit une terre d'espérance
et non pas une terre de résignation
battons nous pour que la france retrouve
sa vocation universelle et sa place au
premier rang en europe et battons-nous
mes chers amis
battons-nous pour la france et pour la
république
je remercie
oh
et
pendant foulée